&gt;&gt; To start off, we need to figure out what two numbers add to equal 10, and
multiply to equal negative 24. It took me a little while to come up with these,
since there are so many different sets of numbers that multiplied equal negative
24, but it turns out that our two numbers are positive 12, and negative 2. Once
we use those in the expression, you can go through just like we normally do.
This gives us the quantity, x plus 2, times the quantity 6x minus 2. But
remember what we said about factoring. We're not done fully factoring if there
are any common terms left within any of our factors. Notice that 6 and negative
2 share a common factor of 2. We can pull out the 2, and then rearrange the
order of our factors, but this looks a little bit more normal. And here's our
final answer. 2 times the quantity x plus 2, times the quantity 3x minus 1.
There is however, one other way we could have done this. We can notice, right
off the bat, that all of our coefficients in the original expression have a
common factor of, guess what, 2. Now this expression inside here is pretty
easily factorable as well, and we won't run into the problem that we did
earlier, of having common factors left within our factors at the end. Go ahead
and try it on your own to see if doing the problem this way gives you the same
answer as the other way did. Hint, it should end up exactly the same, since
we're starting with the same expression.